welcome to the movieclips trailers  channel we're movie freaks movie psychos  movie maniacs we know movies and because  we're fans ourselves we know that when  you're trying to find the hot new  trailer release YouTube can be a little  chaotic we're here to save the day we  give you the best most up-to-date movie  content with over 5 million subscribers  we are YouTube's biggest movie trailer  trailer we receive over 23 million views  per week one day eight point five years  of content is watched on this channel we  are the one stop shop you've been  looking for so stop searching for  trailers and start watching them click  Subscribe if the hottest new trailers  delivered directly to you  you